bonjour maman qu'est ce qu'il y a je
dois m'absenter quelque temps
on m'a demandé d'attirer un homme dans
un hôtel
il disait que c'était un ennemi de
l'état retire ta robe et en échanges et
ma mère aurait eu les soins dont elles
avaient besoin
au final ils ont égorgé il ne devait y
avoir aucun témoin alors réellement
donné le choix morere ou devenir la
moindre
[Musique]
à compter de ce jour vous serez des
moines ans
des armes dans une lutte mondiale pour
le pouvoir
[Musique]
serez formé à la manipulation
psychologique vous devrez apprendre à
aller au-delà de tous vos a perdi
déshabillez vous quand nous en aurons
fini avec toi
la personne que tu étais n'existera plus
tout être humain est une mosaïque de
besoin vous devez devenir la pièce
manquante et il vous dira où tu à redon
tu sais comment survivre
tu es né pour faire ce travail
il ya un traître au gouvernement son
dernier contact connu est un américain
devient un intime avec lui je crois vous
avoir vu à la piscine nous allons
devenir amis c'est ce que vous voulez
c'est un moineau vous ne comptez que
tant que vous leur aide utile à
travailler avec moi et réglez vos
comptes avec eux
tu nous surpasse tous dans ce domaine
quand seul problème c'est que tu as une
âme
on peut rien croire de ce qui sort de sa
bouche
il y à quelque chose d'autre qu'on ne
voit pas
si elle est compromise il faudra
l'éliminer est ce que tu es
tu leur appartient ils ne te laisseront
jamais partir je trouverai un moyen
[Musique]